on Friday the government regulator in
charge the FDIC took control of Silicon
Valley Bank's assets and over the
weekend it took control of signature
Banks assets
treasury secretary Yellen and a team of
banking Regulators have taken action
immediate action and here are the
highlights first all customers who had
deposits in these Banks can rest assured
I want to rest assured they'll be
protected and they'll have access to
their money as of today
that includes small businesses across
the country that bank there and need to
make payroll pay their bills and stay
open for business
no losses and I want this is an
important point no losses will be borne
by the taxpayers let me repeat that no
losses will be borne by the taxpayers
instead the money will come from the
fees that Banks pay into the deposit
Insurance Fund because of the actions of
that because of the actions that our
regular is already taken every American
should feel confident that their
deposits will be there if and when they
need them second the management of these
banks will be fired if the bank is taken
over by FDIC the people running the bank
should not work there anymore
third investors in the banks will not be
protected
they knowingly took a risk and when the
risk didn't pay off investors lose their
money that's how capitalism works
and fourth there are important questions
of how these Banks got into circumstance
in the first place
we must get the full accounting of what
happened and why those responsible can
be held accountable
and my Administration no one in mind no
one is above the law and finally we must
reduce the risk of this happening again
during the Obama Biden Administration we
put in place tough requirements on banks
like Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank including the Dodd-Frank law to
make sure that the crisis we saw in 2008
would not happen again unfortunately the
last Administration rolled back some of
these requirements I'm going to ask
Congress and the banking Regulators to
strengthen the rules for banks to make
it less likely this kind of bag failure
would happen again and to protect
American jobs and small businesses
look the bottom line is this Americans
can rest assured that our banking system
is safe your deposits are safe let me
also assure you we will not stop at this
we'll do whatever is needed on top of
all that let's also take a look at a
moment to put the situation in a broader
context
we've made strong economic progress in
the past two years we've created more
than 12 million new jobs more jobs in
two years than any president has ever
created in a single four-year term
unemployment is below four percent for
14 straight months
take-home pay for workers is going up
especially for lower and middle income
workers
and we've seen record numbers of people
apply to start new businesses more than
10 million of them more than 10 million
applications over the last two years
starting businesses now we need to keep
the program this progress going
that's what Swift action that my
Administration over the past few years
is all about protecting depositors
protecting the banking system protecting
the economic gains we've made together
for the American people